one thing that like it's hard to wrap
your head around is that I when I wrote
this so I wrote that piano line the
chords the chorus all of my I wrote some
raps I did all of the programming for
all the Beats sitting in a rehearsal
space on Hollywood and Vine
overnight they they had these like I
love them you weren't supposed to say
overnight you weren't supposed to stay
overnight but it they let me stay there
um because I wanted to kind of spend
more time with the music and outside it
was like you know junkies and
prostitutes right now now it's like a
like a fancy sushi spot like back then
it was bad like I I literally we locked
the doors and everything
um to the whole unit because we didn't
want anybody getting in that song did
not exist we you know it never existed
you're sitting there
this is the first part that's the part
that came to you and do you run over to
the piano and start hitting it again and
again and again
I was already doodling on the piano and
it that came to me
and let that run yeah and then do the
lyrics start coming to you I knew I
wanted to do the back and forth like he
would sing a line and then I would rap
my lyrics in the first version were
different
but the chorus I think by the end of
that session that night I think I had
written the words to the chorus if I'm
not mistaken if not no it had to be
because the next day I played it for our
drummer and our drummer Rob was like
dude this is the song that we've been
waiting for like this is the best song
we've got and right here this part I had
by the end of the by the end of the
night I had this I think did you get the
chills when you wrote this part because
it's like I don't even know really what
you're saying in terms of a meaning but
the vibe is [__] mind-blowing right
here
it didn't feel big to me it didn't feel
like a hit song I wouldn't know what a
hit song felt like wow I was too young
all I was was like all it was was
I was feeling despondent I was feeling
like
what you know we're doing all this stuff
we're trying to like
realize some kind of identity or some
kind of like meaning and it doesn't it's
not working it doesn't in the end all
this [__] we're doing doesn't matter we
were going nowhere it was just it was
there was a despondence in it and you
know what blows my mind too
you bring it to Chester and Chester goes
we're not putting this on the album this
is not a good song
he didn't hate it no no no no that's
actually a misconception some people
think that he he hated the song he liked
the song he just loved really heavy
stuff and so when we were like when
people were like this should be a single
he was like uh whatever like that's fine
like it's not it was not the one he
would have chose listening to this note
what do you feel when you hear it
he was born for this yeah I feel like I
feel like this him singing vocals on
albums
and on stage was as happy as it got like
that was as good as it [__] got so I
think I feel good I always feel good
about that